how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and everything
relating to the MCU and today we have
some spider-man 3 news and this news is
actually coming from Sony Pictures and
Hyundai the car company I know that
probably sounds kind of weird but as
you've probably noticed Marvel Studios
usually partners up with a car company
for their films Iron Man's outtie is a
great example the Audi that Captain
America showed up to Iron Man's cabin in
an Avengers in game was a great example
as well and the decked out Chevy Tahoe
that Nick Fury drove and Captain America
the Winter Soldier is a great example as
well well today Sony struck a deal with
Hyundai for their cars to be in
spider-man 3 and the cars will be in the
movie in a very specific way so we'll
break down the support and talk about
what it means if you're new be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a
spider-man Funko pop so this was
reported from a deadline and the report
reads as follows Hyundai Motors new
models and technologies will star in
five upcoming Sony movies including
uncharted the sequel to spider-man far
from home the sequel to spider-man into
the spider verse and other 10 polska to
be determined and it goes on to say the
deal will marry Sony Pictures IP with
Hyundai's technology and designs
specifically bring into life the
automakers human-centered future
mobility vision which is dedicated to
revitalizing cities and galvanizing
urban air mobility the partnership will
leverage Sony Pictures IP for marketing
content and immersive entertainment
collaborate on infrastructure and
vehicular concepts for Sony movies
co-create virtual reality and gaming
experience and co-produce events among
other opportunities Hyundai will also
offer substantial marketing support so
what does this mean and why do we really
care well it could actually be quite
revealing about the plot of spider-man 3
at the end of Spider Man fire from home
Mysterio revealed spider-man's identity
as Peter Parker he also pinned him as a
murderer and we know from the Morbius
trailer that the population views him as
a murderer so as many people have
predicted he's going to be on the run
and it sounds like Hyundai is going to
help with that Peter Parker is used to
having technology in fact one of
coolest scenes from far from home was
where Peter was in Tony Stark's plane
making his new spider-man suit well it
sounds like Hyundai is kind of going to
fill that role here because we know that
Peter is going to have some sort of help
in spider-man 3 he's not just going to
get abandoned by everybody who loves him
specifically happy and pepper there's no
way that they're going to believe that
he killed Mysterio and tried to murder a
bunch of people so they're definitely
going to help him out and it sounds like
they may be given him a super advanced
car one that will have a lot of
technology and one that will probably
involve a lot of chase scenes but from
what this report from deadline says it
doesn't sound like they're going to be
your ordinary chase scenes the report
says that Sony is going to bring
Hyundai's technology and designs and the
automakers human-centered future
mobility vision to the screen they also
said that they're going to have very
immersive entertainment so we know that
spider-man is going to be on the run we
know that he's going to have some help
from somebody at start technologies and
it sounds like this car could probably
play a big part in him getting around
without being detected
and once he is detected we're probably
going to get a few really good chase
scenes in the movie involving Hyundai
this lines up perfectly with everything
that we know about the film spider-man
being on the run running away from the
authorities because again we know from
the Morbius trailer that people believed
Mysterio's video people do think that
Peter Parker is spider-man and that he
killed Mysterio so essentially a good
amount of the movie is going to be a
chase and it sounds like Peter Parker is
going to have a very advanced car to
help him get away throughout the film
and that car is going to be provided by
Hyundai and of course Stark Industries
in the movie but let me know what you
think about this report of Hyundai being
super involved in spider-man 3 leave
your thoughts and comments down below
also don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man 3 you
can follow me on Twitter for live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
you